SIMU LIU
Hello everyone, we're from the cast of
Marvel Studios' Shang-Chi
and the Legend of the Ten Rings,
and today we're going to play
a game that'll hopefully let you know
a little bit more
about our characters.
KATY
You got this. Don't be nervous.
SHANG-CHI
Thank you.
MENG'ER ZHANG
Me.
SIMU LIU
[Laughing] That was fast!
AWKWAFINA
Yes.
MENG'ER ZHANG
Right?
SIMU LIU
Yes... Like, your character or you?
I just want to make sure
that you know, also you!
KATY
You're, like, such a badass.
Everything that you do
is, like, so cool.
AWKWAFINA
You.
SIMU LIU
You think it's me?
AWKWAFINA
Shang would make a snarky...
like, a "well, let's go, big boy!"
MENG'ER ZHANG
[Laughing]
SIMU
Shang is known to say that.
AWKWAFINA
I'm ready to rumble, big boy...
What, I don't know what
men say, "why so big, big boy?"
[Laughing]
AWKWAFINA
Both of you guys.
You have superhero
genetics, are you kidding me?
SIMU LIU
Here's the thing, how many times can you
punch a zombie without,
like, without getting bit?
KATY
Oh. Right.
AWKWAFINA
Definitely me, and that was one time!
And it was just my Social!
No, really. Couple times.
MENG'ER ZHANG
Not me.
SIMU LIU
I don't know, I've never done that
character work before.
I got to really reach down and go like,
what does my character want for coffee?
SIMU LIU
Trick question! All of us, it's all of us.
We save the world together
because we're a super team.